Let's learn about Giraffes!
With long, long necks, and long legs, giraffes are the tallest living land animals.
Some giraffes reach a height of more than 17 feet.
They're mammals, which means they are warm-blooded,...
...they have fur, and they feed their babies milk.
Giraffes live in Africa, south of the Sahara Desert.
They prefer to live in open woodland or grassland,...
...where they eat the leaves from trees that other animals can't reach.
Giraffes are herbivores or plant-eaters.
They can eat leaves from acacia trees...
...because their long tongues and tough lips let them eat around the thorns.
Lions will sometimes kill and eat giraffes,...
...but usually the giraffes' long necks lets them see trouble coming...
...and they just run away before the lions can catch them.
That's why giraffes travel in herds.
There's always someone watching for trouble.
To stay safe, giraffes stay standing up almost all of the time.
They eat standing up, they sleep standing up...
...they even have their babies while they're standing up.